1.5 million people have now escaped
russia's war in ukraine it's europe's
biggest refugee crisis since the end of
the second world war can the continent
cope and what should be the eu's policy
response this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
fully battibo russia's invasion of
ukraine has created 1.5 million refugees
in just 10 days the u.n says it's the
fastest growing refugee crisis in europe
since the second world war at least 63
000 ukrainians have gone to romania
slovakia has received 101 000 while
moldova's president says more than 250
000 have arrived in her country
nearly 160 000 are in hungary but the
biggest number of ukrainian refugees are
in poland which has received more than
756
000
while refugees have been reporting
having to wait for days to cross border
checkpoints aid agencies and volunteers
are doing whatever they can to help
i brought the kids to romania with my
mom and sister and her kids also they're
going to stay here and i'm going back to
ukraine
i arrived with my sister and my children
but my husband and my mom stayed over
there we didn't want to come here but my
husband insisted on it
it's kind of horrible because
i had certain plans for my life in the
upcoming months and all of them were
kind of shaken at the moment because i
was planning to be present in ukraine
and kiev in a lot of other cities but
now with the situation i cannot continue
neither anything related to my career
back in ukraine and i kind of need to
start over things again being in poland
well the un's high commissioner for
refugees has told al jazeera the flow of
people will increase in the coming days
what we also hear is that
hundreds of thousands are on the move so
and this is the prediction of the border
guards here who by the way are doing a
very good job
they
predict that the flow will increase not
decrease in the next few days and
perhaps beyond bombs continue to rain on
cities people will leave
and the european union commission says
it's going to take a lot of help to
manage the influx
european union as ukraine's neighbor
is sparing no effort
we're providing 500 million euros of
humanitarian aid immediately and more
will come
we're working fast to establish civil
protection hubs in poland and slovakia
and romania
and we are also doing everything we can
with international organizations and
ngos to set up humanitarian corridors
that stretch inside ukraine
well let's now bring in our guests in
warsaw we have monica matus a human
rights activist and spokeswoman for
grouper granica a coalition of ngos
that's been supporting refugees in
geneva babar baloch a spokesman for the
united nations high commissioner for
refugees and in brussels alberto
knightheart policy analysts for the
european diversity and migration program
at the european policy center thank you
all for joining us on inside story we
appreciate your time monica let me start
with you in warsaw poland your
organization has been
on the front lines of this crisis we're
talking now about more than half a
million refugees arriving in poland
alone in the last 10 days give us some
perspective first about what your teams
have seen at the border with ukraine and
and whether the flow has increased
or is it slowing in these past few days
i don't think the flow is uh slowing in
the last few days uh i think it's a bit
fluctuating uh like
you know some days uh there's a little
bit less people some days there's more i
think it also depends on the
what's happening actually in ukraine and
uh during the war but we are expecting
more or less the same
flow so to speak of people over the next
days or weeks even
um at the moment uh as you mentioned uh
like there's over seven hundred thousand
yesterday in poland in polish media
we heard the number eight hundred
thousand people that have arrived
already
in poland uh mostly it's uh it's
ukrainian mothers with children elderly
uh people but also uh of course there's
quite a lot of um foreigners who are who
don't have ukrainian passports so a lot
of african students
a lot of people from third countries uh
who are also passing and fleeing the war
these are people who've had their lives
monika ripped apart in the last 10 days
and many have left their loved ones
inside ukraine you mentioned that most
were women and children because the men
have stayed to fight on right what have
they told you about their journey to
poland and what is right now their their
short-term need and what do you expect
their medium and long-term needs to be
so of course the journey is quite
difficult already because uh you know
the trains the the buses are over
absolutely over overloaded and uh then
they have to wait for long long long
hours sometimes days
to actually get uh to the to the proper
border crossing
uh
we um and many volunteers uh from our
side but also from you know local
authorities
um they are providing humanitarian
assistance along the queues like going
into ukraine but also on the polish side
uh we know that the short-term need so
short-term needs
all the time increasing i would say are
um you know transporting these people
providing the shelter providing food um
providing some sort of
legal assistance very quickly like
making them understand what is their
legal situation in poland and in the
european union
and then a long-term assistance which is
growing but also will be growing next
days yes um on making these people
understand what to do next and what they
can do next right
it is indeed growing as we heard from
the u.n uh refugee chief earlier uh baba
balochi in geneva let me ask you about
the scope of the crisis unhcr talks
about this being the largest refugee
crisis in a century why what makes this
the largest refugee crisis in a century
especially when you consider that a
country like syria for example
has had what over five million six
million syrians leave the country uh
during the conflicts there what's
different this time around
indeed i mean the similarity in terms of
the devastation wars bring is the same
its impact on all human beings as you've
heard it disrupts life it turns apart
uh uh people's living you know and
there's death uh destruction and
displacement what we are saying is we
have not witnessed this pace
uh in in recent times a hundred thousand
people or even more than hundred
thousand people fleeing uh within a day
the number is 1.5 million within the 10
days this is just not an ordinary number
these are human beings and millions of
others who are inside ukraine that have
have been affected uh so this has not
been seen this is europe's fastest
growing uh humanitarian crisis of of the
century and at what's encouraging uh
just let me add there is the outpour of
support that we have so far seen the
best of humanity in the neighboring
countries right 1.5 million babar have
fled uh ukraine what do we know about
those who are still inside those who are
internally displaced how bad is the
situation for them and is unhcr able to
reach them
it is really bad uh you cannot get a
clear picture in terms of the overall
number of displacement in the in the
country because it's unpredictable it's
very dangerous for people we know that
millions are on the move uh in terms of
seeking safety inside the country unhcr
has
remained in ukraine and in the
neighboring countries we are bringing
help as much as we we can we are also
bringing supplies from other places uh
uh like for instance poland we are
taking things inside ukraine to help in
the western parts of poland but also in
cave where we had some supplies we are
trying to go out and and support and and
as as it was mentioned the way things
are going the fear is more people will
be affected more will be displaced more
will become
refugees and that's why it's very
important that the guns have to fall
silent alberto neihart in brussels as
babar said there
tremendous solidarity especially from
european governments some rare consensus
from member states
on how to deal with the influx of
refugees from ukraine this time around
tell us more first about what the eu has
done to help those who've been coming in
well to begin with the european
commission has provided operational
assistance and has coordinated efforts
of the country's neighboring
ukraine but
clearly from what monica and baba have
said
it is clear that
these countries will not be able on
their own to offer uh sufficient
protection or
to cover the needs in the short and in
the long term
of those fleeing from ukraine and so for
this reason
interior ministers of the eu have met
last thursday and they took the
unanimous decision to introduce or
activate better the temporary protection
directive and this is a an unprecedented
and also historic uh moment this is a
group uh based form of immediate
protection that gives
residents rights and access to the labor
market uh to those who are uh eligible
for the protection it also gives the
possibility to the many families that
are
escaping ukraine to enroll their
children in uh school alberto but can
europe i'm sorry to interrupt you
because it is very important what you're
saying but i want to know whether europe
can cope
what are the challenges first uh you
know short and medium term for for
european governments you know with all
these refugees coming in
there will be challenges and i think
it's also important that the uh the
public at large uh is aware of them
there are many questions to begin with
where will these pearsons go uh some of
them of course will try to reach their
family members and extended communities
and so there is a question about how the
countries that will receive the lion's
share
of those running for their lives will
guarantee access to the labor market or
sufficient housing there are also
questions about those who won't be able
to travel across europe
to find safety so what uh sort of
solidarity will be uh guaranteed by the
european union to these persons another
challenge in the uh medium term will be
how to uh support financially uh local
authorities as well as central
governments that will host uh ukrainians
and other groups running from ukraine
okay well let's uh pause a moment and
take a look at how this crisis has been
dealt with compared to previous ones as
you've heard from alberto there for the
first time the eu has proposed
triggering a special rule called a
temporary protection directive to help
ukrainian refugees they'll have the
right to live and work in the block for
up to three years without a visa but the
directive's text was changed to only
protect ukrainian nationals and
long-term residents
hungary and romania are offering cash
for food and clothing and to educate
ukrainian children in local schools the
uk is setting up a scheme to help
businesses sponsor ukrainian refugees
now let's compare that to other recent
humanitarian crises with 6.6 million
refugees the war in syria is the world's
biggest refugee emergency european
countries took in 1 million of them
mostly between germany and sweden and
there are 2.6 million registered afghan
refugees the eu agreed in december to
resettle 40 000 of them
so monica let me come to you in poland
first because uh the way poland has
reacted to this crisis is
very different from the reaction when we
saw the the migrant and refugee crisis
at the border with belarus a few months
ago
how do you explain this
i don't have words for this we are we
are actually quite
i mean it's very difficult emotions as
well for us because uh me myself even uh
we were on the polish belarusian border
for months actually pulling people out
of the forest so you can imagine like
what kind of strange feelings we have
when we then go to the polish ukrainian
border and
you don't have to actually you know
crawl in the forest in the dark to
provide uh food and water to
to children and people and
here you like we welcome them with the
open arms we are absolutely happy that
the polish government is is you know
welcoming so openly and we are welcoming
openly as well ukrainians but uh and
non-ukrainian uh you know citizens but
um
it is still appalling just yesterday um
we heard again about you know a group of
eight syrian people being pushed back to
belarus on the polish belarusian border
so this discrepancy this kind of
unexplainable you know uh uh
policy
is still there and is still in place and
uh the things on the polish belarusian
border are still happening
i i cannot expect i i don't know what's
the what's the idea behind this i think
uh it's it's it's i i could use the word
racism but i i don't know if it's racism
if it's just a you know eu policy
uh sort of
narrative for many years and not opening
the borders so much to
non-neighboring countries right
let's ask alberto about what he thinks
about this this discrepancy alberto how
do you explain this what should we make
of europe's schizophrenic uh refugee
response
well first of all i understand perfectly
the claim that what we are seeing now
are
double standards and indeed the
situation in poland is uh quite
illustrative of a trend that we have
seen for many years uh you mentioned
before the syrian crisis and the
inability of member states to reach
consensus on how to divide
responsibility and offer protection for
the many hundreds thousands of people
who were also running from a conflict i
i think that
possibly the geographical proximity to
the world itself may have
led to a significant change in
perception
in the european public but it is also
clear that
it also depends on european governments
and their response and how they frame
the emergency that determines
a change in sensitivity in the public at
large to go back to what monica was
saying i think we are seeing
clearly an overwhelming outpour of
solidarity from ordinary citizens but
it's also clear that this will not be
sustainably in the long term and so
member states and the eu
as they all will be called to its
responsibility to
offer protection to everybody in the
case of these conflict to ukrainians and
others who are running for their lives
from ukraine but it's also necessary to
offer protection without discrimination
on the basis of nationality or any other
factor and for these reasons it is
important and i hope that this will be a
watershed moment that will also
determine determine a change
of intent and and more courage on the
part of the eu uh to uh have a
consolidated common european asylum
system uh in the future
your thoughts about this europe says it
will give these refugees extended rights
to stay in the european union but these
protections from what i understand for
now will only apply to refugees who are
ukrainian citizens right so what happens
to all those who are from
third countries the third nationals
who've also tried to escape this
conflict what concessions should be
offered to them safety i mean that's
very important everyone who is running a
situation of war and and conflict has to
find a safety or you don't become
refugee by choice
and countries have legal and moral
obligations and that's why it's very
important that humanity cannot be
applied selectively uh saying that also
we have seen even in the other crisis uh
neighbors
have stepped forward uh hosting refugees
at the same scale i mean majority of
syrians majority of afghans uh majority
of those those who are fleeing conflict
in in africa and and the rohingyas they
have been taken care by uh the neighbor
that's why the word solidarity is very
important even in this context as well
and we see when when the civil society
when populations when the governments
everyone comes together
we can deal with humanitarian disasters
better and give some hope to the people
who are affected by our conflict and war
monica on solidarity is the polish
government are polish authorities
preparing for the presence of these
refugees in the long run you think
i don't think so i mean uh
first of all as it was said already it's
unprecedented so i i don't think any
government would be would be able to
handle it
well you know but uh
just over a week ago just when the when
the war started um the the polish
minister of you know internal affair
first came on tv and said we are very
well prepared we have been preparing for
many weeks which was absolutely not not
true at the time a lot of uh or majority
of the work which is now being done
i think it it stays on the shoulders of
local authorities non-governmental you
know groups initiatives organizations
i am seeing this every day i was also
talking uh to many representatives of
local authorities they quite complain
for the lack of you know support from
the government
and i don't think um that there is a
sort of a long-term thinking already in
play i would love to i would i would
love to hear about this if there is some
but i think at the moment um it's just
really sort of dealing with emergency
yeah speaking of dealing with the
emergency barbara there's been talk
there's been discussion of setting up a
humanitarian corridor that would allow
you know safe passage for the refugees
for the people who are still inside how
would that work i mean and would that
help you think
it's needed uh i mean first we need this
this war to end i mean as you heard uh
the unhigh commissioner for refugees
philippo grandi as far as bombs are
falling uh people have to run uh for for
safety and that's why we are very
concerned those people uh who need a
safe passage uh to to get out
it it has to be implemented right now
that's the need uh in in inside ukraine
and and then we can try to support on
humanitarian bases in terms of agencies
like unicr and others uh icrc and and
and others in in terms of uh uh kind of
making this possible logistically it is
possible but security wise we need the
guarantees from all sides to to to make
it happen and it should happen as soon
as possible security guarantees babar
what about financially money-wise what
what are the needs right now
we launched as as as the u.n and the
humanitarian larger community we
launched
like a week ago in a funding appeal for
1.7 billion us dollars for just the
short term uh
and this was for inside ukraine and also
for those countries that have been
receiving uh refugees uh the support has
been outpouring in terms of finances as
well there have been many contributions
we as unicr have received more than 200
million u.s dollars to support
refugees and also people inside but this
is just short term
more will be needed more support will be
needed it's also encouraging to see
not governments but individuals
businesses and foundations coming
forward to to contribute support is
coming but more is needed you say babar
alberto i'll give you the last word the
eu's migration policy looking ahead now
i mean there were proposals for uh
legislative reform uh to eu migration uh
and asylum law on the table even before
this ukraine conflict began do you see
this being hurried now and and do you
expect concrete steps
uh to be taken towards addressing the
gaps that have existed like i said this
is a historic moment and uh um to answer
your question i i believe that the
divisions uh and the sticking points of
the past will not be forgotten overnight
i think they will remain
divisions and and uh disagreements
between member states in the south south
and and northwest and east of of of
europe but what is clear uh based on
what we are seeing now is that there is
more that brings these countries
together then set them apart
so the question is in this context
if the broader set of reforms will be
able to move forward
i believe that
it is
again in these moments that the best and
the worst of
of of uh persons and countries and and
governments uh is revealed and i truly
believe and hope
that the you will manage to find
a common ground on on the policies that
are badly needed
one last point on
what was said by the other speakers i
think there is also a change of mindset
that is needed at this point from the
short term to the long term
because again
the
need is now to provide food
and shelter but in the long term there
will be a need to provide
housing and work to those escaping from
the conflict it is this kind of thinking
that will underpin
sustainable reforms in this area without
it i think this is going to be a an
emergency that will not be solved uh in
in the short run uh by
common efforts by european countries
so solutions needed in the short term
but also in the long term thank you very
much to all three of you for a very
interesting discussion monica matus baba
baloch and alberto neihart
and thank you for watching you can
always watch this program again anytime
by visiting our website at aljazeera.com
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is our aj inside story from
me fully [ __ ] whole team here in
doha thanks for watching bye for now
[Music]